وبالنظر إلى قرب نهاية الأسبوع
وإذن الاستخدام الطارئ المحتمل
للقاح الحديث ،
ما الذي تتعلمه عن كيفية
اختلاف اللقاح الثاني عن
اللقاح الذي تستخدمه شركة فايزر
جيدًا ، كما تعلم ، يمكننا أن نوضح لك أننا
جمعنا بعض الحقائق الأكثر صلة بالموضوع
حول  هذه اللقاحات متشابهة جدًا ،
فكلاهما لقاح rna messenger ،
يتم فصل اللقاح الحديث بأربعة
أسابيع على عكس pfizer واحدًا تلو
الآخر ، لا يحتاج اللقاح الحديث إلى أن
يظل باردًا بحيث قد يوفر بعضًا
نوع التوزيع الأوسع للقنوات
لذلك
أنت تعرف أن شيئًا واحدًا كان صفقة كبيرة
الأسبوع الماضي ، تتذكر
أندرسون هو أن شركة فايزر العمرية التي جربت الأشخاص الذين يبلغون من العمر
16 عامًا أو أكبر ، والقناة الحديثة
تبلغ من العمر 18 عامًا أو أكبر ، ولكن اللقاحات المتشابهة جدًا
شيء واحد يظهر
شيئًا أنت و  تحدثت
الليلة الماضية
عن اللقاح أندرسون هل نعلم أنه يمنع
المرض والسؤال الكبير هل يمنع أيضًا
العدوى أه الأعمال الورقية
الحديثة التي أطلقوها  dum بعد
إصدار التقرير الكامل
الذي قال بشكل أساسي إنهم قاموا أيضًا بمسح
الأشخاص قبل أن يحصلوا على
جرعتهم الأولى وبين الجرعتين الأولى والثانية
أيضًا وما وجدوه هو
أن هناك الكثير من الأشخاص الذين
لم تظهر عليهم أبدًا أي أعراض تعرفهم
كانوا بدون أعراض تمامًا
ولكن من بين الأشخاص الذين حصلوا بالفعل على
مسحة إيجابية ،
كان العدد الكبير منهم في
الذراع الوهمية
عددًا أقل بكثير كانوا في الذراع الملقحة الفعلية ،
وآمل أن يكون
ذلك منطقيًا بشكل أساسي ، آه لا هؤلاء الأشخاص لم
تظهر عليهم الأعراض  تم مسحهم للتو
كجزء من اختبار المراقبة
ووجدوا أن المجموعة التي تم تلقيحها
تميل إلى أن تكون أقل احتمالية
لوجود الفيروس بالفعل ، لذا تعلم أننا سنرى
ما يعني أنه من الواضح أنه لا
يظهر أنه يحمي تمامًا
من  الأشخاص الذين أصيبوا بالعدوى ولكن
يبدو أن لها بعض
التأثير على هذا ، ونحن نبحث
عن نفس النوع من البيانات من شركة Pfizer
التي يقولون إنها قد تأتي في يناير